[音楽]
こんにちは、みなさん、ようこそ 2022 年 8 月 10 日
にアクティブなライブ ストリーム番号 47.1
です。私たち
は、ペーパー ダイアド、非アクティブな動的
社会的認知、
ヒッパリトとベニスのアクティブな推論、ピエタレンネンとピエタレンネン
によるアクティブな推論と誘拐の調査を続けています。
ベニー インスティテュートへようこそ。私たちは
参加型のラボであり、
学習を伝達し、
適用されたアクティブな推論を実践するインスティテュートです。リンク
はスライドにあります。
これはアーカイブ ライブ ストリームに記録されています。
フィードバックをお寄せください。
背景や視点は
大歓迎
です。ライブ ストリームのビデオ エチケットに従います
。activeinference.org にアクセスし
て、研究所の他のプロジェクトの詳細と、今日のストリーム 47.1 で
学習グループに参加して参加する方法
を学びます。
前述のこの 2 つの論文
と前のビデオ
について説明します。
紹介をしてから、おそらく
誰もが聞きたい新しい質問があるところに飛び込んで
ください。会話に新しいベクトルをもたらすことができるように、紹介を青で終わらせるかもしれません。
私はダニエルです。私はカリフォルニアの研究者で
あり、
これらの角度のいくつかについて学ぶことがたくさんあり、そのこと
について考える
ことがたくさんあったので、0.1 レンズを拡張ドット 0 を持つ紙に少し持っていくのを楽しみにしています
[音楽]
とは
浴槽に入ってから
紙のペアの真ん中にいること
と、たとえばそれを
文脈化するために入ったり
、その間に何かを適用しようとしたりすることの違い
。ディーンに渡します。
ありがとうございます。 ディーン私はここカルガリーにいますええと
、ドットワンが何を意味するのかわかりません.2つのものを引き寄せようとした
ドットワンを行ったことがないので、
それらを近位に置いて何が起こるかを見てください.
時々それは
火と水であり、ただたくさんの
蒸気を得るからです 時々それはニトロと
グリセリンであり、すべてが
あなたに爆発するので、私は
それ
が一種の危険な部分であり、私が
エキサイティングだと思うことを楽しみにしてい
ます.
スティーブン ここトロント
にいます アクティブな影響力へのこの 2 つの異なるアプローチ
の融合が何を
もたらすのか、非常に興味があります。 リアリズムをもたらすことに焦点を当てて
いるので、興味があり、うまくいけば、
それが有用で実用的になることを願っています。
それを青に渡します。
こんにちは、私は青です、私はニューメキシコに
い
ます。
前に別のライブ ストリームでヒッポリトの論文を書いた
と思うので、以前に読んだことがありますが、
このアブダクションを読むのは本当に楽しかった
し、フランスの論文で活動し
ていました。 このように
これは何ですか、それは何
ですか、ウィキペディアを1億回検索して、哲学的
な側面からより多くの情報を取得する必要
があります。
この誘拐論文の積極的な推論
と誘拐
は
、ええと、彼らが提示したように最初にブランケットで最初に提示したの
なぜですか？
私が聞いた話では 2 つのスレッドが青くなりました。
私たちがスライドに乗って同時に見ることができる 2 つの領域だと思います。1
つは、さまざまな分野や分野のさまざまなバックグラウンドのように、個人が取ることができるさまざまなアプローチのようなものでした。
そして、ある
人の単なる学習軌道を超え
て、この場合のアクティブな推論に使用できる概念的アプローチは何かを考え
ますが、これは研究になるかもしれません
i アクティブな推論を行ったり、アクティブな推論を適用したりすること
は、両方の方法で行われる可能性
があり
、状況に応じた現実主義者
や
楽器奏者を可能にするもののどのような側面が、
なぜ人々が取っているスタンスを取っているのかなど、最初の質問とブランケットの問題が発生する可能性があり
ます
[音楽]
特定の状況では、
時には同じシステムの
異なるコンテキストに混在するように、
彼らは1つ
または別のものを使用するか、そのスティーブンのようなものを使用する可能性が
あり、これにより
アクションが方程式に戻され
ます。
ある種の楽器が使われている
のは、それが毛布
に何が起こっているかを考える最良の方法
です.実際、あなたが毛布を持ち出したのは本当にクールだと思い
ます。
誘惑は
すべてを現実的にすることであり、それから
大丈夫です、私たちは毛布を持っているので、
多分私たちは これらすべてのトラップを回避するために、
包括的な質問を道具的な方法で維持する必要
があります。
反対側で
は、数学の側面では、
これらの
潜在的に基本的な
ダイナミクスと
同様に、何らかの方法で行動しているため、いくつかの
必要があります
何らかの形で現実
との関係
があるので、ほぼ鏡のようなものです 鏡で
はありませんが、興味深い方法で反対側に座っているものです その時点からディーンがどう考えているかはわかりません
が、ええと
[音楽]
私
はしようとしていました
私たちが2つの論文を取り、
実際
にそれらが絡み合ったときに何が起こるかを少し
調べているとしたら、主題やトピックとしての
積極的な
推論ではなく、プロセスとして何かが積極的に推論されたときに何が起こるかを見ていると思います.
これを行うとき、本質的に次のスライドの
1 つで大きな問題が何であるかを尋ねていることになり
ます。
積極的に推論するプロセスとしてのアクティブな推論と、
何かが脱落するプロセスの両方としてのアクティブな推論です。 それと私
たちは
、処理としての
グリッパーとグリップされるプロセスの両方であるという比喩を使用して
それを尋ねました。
行為の意味からではなく、
観察の意味または参加の意味から、
ええと
、両方の間で何らかのやり取りが必要であると言わざるを得ないと思いますが、
それは私の見解に過ぎ
ない
ので、この引用を読ませてください
論文 ええと、特にブランケットに戻ると
、私の質問ベルを鳴らしたものは、
答えられていないようなものです
ええと、最近
の fep の解釈による
と、生命システムと外界の動的な相互作用は
能動的推論の下で
可能です これは
、
感覚状態が現実の意味のある
表現である
と仮定することによるラムステッド 2020 の引用です。
fristen によるマルコフブランケットの nt
は、元の特徴付けとは異なり、
確率論的因果ネットワークに関するジュデアパールの作品は、生物と環境
の関係の現実主義的解釈を認め
ている
ため、多くの治療におけるマルコフブランケットとパールブランケットの概念の役割について述べています。
自由
エネルギー原理は道具主義的な
ものであるのに対し、ピアスのさらに強力な
用語
では、その意味の唯名論的解釈を最初に認める
ブランケットでは、非道具主義的な意味だけでなく、
非唯名論的な実体であるという意味でも現実主義者
である。
考えられるもの、想像力によって生み出されるもの、または
将来の事態に予期的に関連するものなどの現実の可能性への言及
は、理論の重要な側面を理解するために使用されます。
それは必然的にそれ自体がリアリズムに関連している
ので、
ダニエルのように多分ケンドヨ 現実主義者の
ように
、初めての毛布は
真珠の毛布の現実主義者の解釈である、
または
その部分を読んだときに
唯名論が何であるかを知らなかったことを忘れているだけな
ので、要約によると
、ビュー ユニバーサルと抽象
オブジェクトは、単なる名前またはラベルである以外には実際には存在しない
こと
一方のバージョンはユニバーサルの存在を否定し
、もう一方は抽象的であるため、
反ジェネラリストの立場であるため
、最初のブランケットで使用された場所を見
てみましょう。 ええと
[音楽]
議論の核心は、
単にうまく言うこと以外の接触のフロンティアの 1 つです 活動主義
と動的システム理論は、このように
大まかに機能するか、この広範な数学
と化学がこのように連携します
これは本当の接触に入り始めています
意味論的に
争われている縄張りのポイントは
、さまざまなコンテキストでベースグラフを解釈する方法についてさまざまな視点を持っている
ため、t 彼はマルコフブランケット
です。その芝全体を何らかの
ビューで制御するには、まだ粗すぎる可能性がある
ようです。それでは
、アブダクションペーパー
や他の何かがどの
よう
にあなたの感覚でより正当化されるかを見てみましょう
ええと
[音楽]
何をしたら、これを開梱し
ます。これは、今日議論するためにコピーされたものだと思う
ので、
両方の論文がマークアップブランケットに関する見解について話して
いる明確な領域であるため、
複数の
ブランケットとグラフに関する見解
が登場しますが
、唯名論
者の解釈を見て、両方の視点を展開しましょう。
展開しているように、それは仏教
の非常に顕著なテーマであるため、調べる必要はありませんでした。
その存在は名目上のような固有の存在のようなもので
は
ないので、この
アブダクション論文
で
彼らがこれを取っているのは興味深いことです ええと、
あなたは唯名論の突き刺しによる構築を知っていますが
、その論文の中で何度もそう
であるように、彼らは客観的な現実を指摘しています。
言語学、意味論、または
おそらく記号論.
ええと、それ
は非常に良い点
です.ええと、私たちがそこで関係について話しているときにあなたが言及したことを結びつけるからです。
それらのリレーショナル
ダイナミクス、またはダイナミクスという言葉を使用しなかったため、
いくつか
は本物と呼ぶことができます。
これはある意味で公正な主張だと思いますが、どれだけ行く
かという質問がある
ため、過剰な拡張がある可能性があることをもう一度知って
います
超越
的で、より多くの形態学
と全体の形態形成にどれだけ下っていくか、そして
実際には本当にグーがあります d
ヘクター・ラザールがいます 彼は実際に
抑圧された人々の劇場で多くの仕事をし
ていて、あなたと一緒に働い
てい
ました
トラウマなどを知ってもらいましょう。興味深いことの 1 つは、
私たちが文化の中
にいる可能性があるということです。物事を説明しようとしたり
、状況を超越し
たり、私たちを避けたりするために超越的な仕事をしたり、実際に状況を回避したりすることがあり
ます。 しかし、傷口に入ると
、
文字通り
血まみれの混乱が見
られる
ことがあるので、通常の意味では現実的ではないかもしれません.
それに少し追加してみましょう.マルコフ毛布の
ほとんどの表現が示すのは興味深いと思います.
プロパティの 2 つの異なる um セットの間のマルコフ ブランケットであり、これは常に
水平方向に表され
ます。ここで興味深いのは
、
あなた自身
が 2 つのトップダウンの視点の議論の状況にある 1 つ
は
、トップダウンからアクティブ
でなければならない、またはトップダウンからでなければならない、いくつ
かの
シリーズの
いくつかのシリーズ、または
精通度に応じて適用される一連の異なるロジック
あなたが観察
していることは、井戸のヒエラルキーの問題全体につながる可能性が
あり、次に何が他のものを伴うのかという
ことです。私にとって
は、道具主義の排他的な立場を取る人々が、
論理
や
ロジックが本物
であり、
従うべきアクションである、またはそれ
が伴うものであるという他の
階層関係. 多くの写真が示す図は、
これにも横方向の側面があることを示している
と思います.
これらの論文の両方のビューの両方が
バイアス
または位置 th 著者の見解では、この一連の条件または状況下でどのような規則が適用
されるかというトップダウンの 1 つであり、
これら 2 つのことをそれぞれの側に配置すること
で、相対性に関するいくつかの問題が取り除かれ
、現在では、権力の観点からの関係ではなく、周囲の関係のアイデアが導入され
ています。
しかし
、
誰かが実際に予測エラーを減らすことができるように
する
ために存在する必要があるものに関する関係は、マークアップブランケットを
変えること
ができると思います。つまり、現在、そのほとんどは
、ある種の垂直パーティションとして認識されています。
横方向の
要素の間 ひっくり返すことができるという
ことです。多くの論文で
、階層構造とは
何か、ボトムアップとは何か、トップダウンとは何かについてよく話してきましたが、
これらの論文は両方とも、
私たちがトップダウンの視点を取っていると確かに言っていると思います
このため、彼らは
自分たち
が見ているよりも積極的に推論する方法で、その中で起こっていることの相対性側面をより強調するように自分自身を制限しています.
感覚と演技の間の関係としてそれを見て
みましょう。たくさんのことがわかり
ました。アブダクション マルコフのブランケット ディスカッションを見てみましょう。
最初の部分は、
哲学的背景の可能性のあるコンテキストのステートメント
ですが、彼らがこれを一緒に配置していることが重要です。
オートポイエシスと生物学の系統なので、これらはおそらく
拡散的なマルチスケールの自己方法で自己永続するシステムですが、
自己創造的です.
環境と非平衡の定常状態を維持しているシステムについて考えています。環境
ではない場合、誰かが環境
のリアリズムや何かを否定した場合
、それは言語化でき、認識さえできますが
、永続的なシステムによって制定されることはありません。
内側からの眺めから、
または
息を止めた場合など、またはそのようなもの、
または外側からの眺めから、
再び p を持つシステム 永続的な
測定
は、少なくとも
環境の規則性の中で持続するのに十分うまく機能している必要がある
ため、これは一種
の進化的および発達
的フレームワークに基づいているが、このリアリズムの議論の基礎となっている
非平衡定常状態維持に接続するような
ものです。
環境との関係が
アプリオリに似ていない場合
、マルコフ ブランケットの定義があります
ベース グラフ内のノード間のブランケット状態の条件付き独立性
は、影響
が移動しないことや、それらの状態
がそれぞれについて意味的にないことを意味するものではありません その他です
が、統計的な方法で条件付きで独立していることを意味します
サボスクの外部状態 この著者はわかりませんが、
エンドソームのビュー
は
、網膜上の光子が本当に軽い
ように、内部で潜在的に意味するようなものです。
エキソセミオティックから記述された生物学的機能と内部状態のその側面内の実物 視点はおそらく解釈的な見方のような
ものなので
、機能の真の影響
とその研究の種類を内側から見る 外側から見ると
、それらが同意する
場合、一時停止の標識のような記号論があり、
それは
異なる状況で停止することを意味します
これは、内部状態
のエントロピーの規制を考えると、アクティブな推論に直接語りかけ
ます。したがって、
境界付き、制約付き、または最小
化されたものとして説明しているこれらすべての機能は、
そのインターフェイスのアクション発信に対するサプライズ制御
と関係があり、その後、バウンド
サプライズに関係しています。 知覚制御理論やさまざま
な運動理論などによって非常に古くなった知覚
についてです
が、反射弧
のように、人々が意思決定をモデル化する方法に挑戦して
います。たとえば、多くの治療法で
、人々は
楽器奏者の用法
や
スタンスを取る
nse は、non および anti との全体的な議論を開始しますが、非ノミナリストのエンティティ
であるという意味でも
、この最後の引用
では
、モーダル参照用語が何であるかについて著者からもっと聞くことができれば幸いです。
ここで際立っているのは本当の可能
性です。
これらの機能がこのように関与しているこれらのシステムでは、これらの機能
をすべて
備えており
、時間の経過とともに環境に結び付けられている限り、認識が現実的であると
見なすこと
ができるためです。 それについて
は、アブダクティブな論文と
非アクティブな論文の多くの段落は、
構造化された議論に実際に関与している場合
、その間に読みたいものがたくさんあり
、彼らが議論を展開した方法を尊重すると
同時に、
うまくいけば今ではすべてが
興味深い方法を見ているからです。 それを接続して、
スティーブン、そして他の誰か、
ええ、
これはあなたのダニエルへのフィードバックのようなもの
です。これについて考えている場合に備えて。
ここであなたが提起している生物学的側面があり、私はそれに
同意します。トリスタン
は脳に関する研究で
、因果的相関から機能的相関への移行について話
していることを知っています。
それが機能している場合はどこかで
、もちろんこの場合
、私たちが科学的に何を現実としているかという特定の要素があります。
なぜなら、それ
は科学者としての科学的リアリズムであり、実際に
科学的に演繹されたものは何なの
かということだ
からです。 特定の状態
で取られている視点の中でそう解釈されて
いる 非平衡定常状態
その
注意の体制は
純粋に考慮されるべき道具であるか
、それが分析している
ことが現実で
ある可能性があるので、存在する可能性があります 一種の脱出
条項
ですが、その下にある視点や論理ではなく、まだ現象が存在する可能性があります
同じ結果に到達するために多くのダイナミクスがある
ので、そのダニエルについてあなたの考えは何ですか
私の考えはブルーとディーンがそれについて何を言うか聞きたいです
オーケーオーケースティーブまず
先に進んでくださいブルーに
行きましょうディーン私
あなたが言わなければならないことを聞きたいのですが
、ここで
両方の論文について興味深いことがあります。おそらく論文の著者はこれに強く反対するかもしれませんが、
それは私
が
両方の論文に慣れていることであり、これについて科学的な
視点を持っています
非常に私の典型的な視点
であり、私の本ではイディオムとして簡単に理解でき
ます。彼ら
は証拠が正しいことを望んで
いると信じています。
これは素晴らしい証拠
だと思いますが、これについて本当に魅力的だと思うの
は、彼らが
その認識論的
優先順位を保持している間、彼らはそれを逆転させることについても多く話していることです。
それを見る
ですから、これには多くの信頼
がありますが、まだ実現していませんが、私
が
社会的環境で存在し続ける
か、エージェントとして
何を推測するかを推測する場合、この間ずっと展開し続けるという信念を持っている必要があります。
目的 目標または
指示を達成
するために
取り組ん
でいます 何かが具体化するその瞬間に実際に到達するまでそれを見ないでください
そして私は言うことができます ああ、
今私は証拠を持っているので、
両方の論文には本物があります
彼らは遊ぶ 彼らは自分自身で遊ぶ 彼らは自分自身で遊ぶ
どちらも
科学的および
数学的に見ているという明確な観点からの論文であるという意味で、自分自身と一緒
に踊って
ください。 私は私です私は私は
定常状態と呼ばれるものです私は
表現を失いました非平衡非平衡状態
ありがとうございます非平衡状態状態私
は何かを信じなければなりません。
o  r
結果 私はそれが
ホメオスタシスかアロスタシスか、または今から 5 分後に挟み込みたいかどうかに向けて進ん
でいます 実際に物事を手に入れる前に、そのこと、私のエージェンシー、または
達成または達成する私の能力を信じ
なければなりません。
その見解だけから見ると
、両方の論文にある程度の素朴さがあることは本当に興味深いと
思います。
何か
に気付くたびに、少しの信念が必要であるというこの新人の見解に敬意を払わなければなりません。 または
、何が起こっているかについての少しの信念が実際に
存在し
、優先順位が何であれ実行したいので、それを使用し
ます。
行動主義の
陰気さ 彼らは両方とも底辺の高さに帽子をかぶってい
ます
私は一種の
自信
を持たなければなりません たとえそれが今ここになくても、ある
時点で
それは私が望むように続くか、
または何でも ch 私はそれに押し付けたいと思って
います 私は
それを待ってそのことが起こる能力を持っている
ので、
そうです、スティーブンが言ったことに追加
します 今、
ファーストとファースト イン
ブランケットの違いと私は
議論しなければならない論文に出くわしました.ええと、それは
リテラル主義のないファースト イン ブランケットについての科学的リアリズムと呼ばれ、
キンバースタインとカーク キルチョフによるものです。
私たちは今
、それが哲学のアーカイブに事前に印刷されていることを確認する必要がある
ので
、実際の境界を持つことは
、文字通りの解釈
または現実主義者の解釈の
ようなものであり、私がまだ試みているように、文字通りのように見えるようです フリステン ブランケットの
この現実主義的解釈とは何かのように絞り込む
ええと
、
それはまた、非常に現実的な意味
で、生き物の本当の境界とは何かのように
ええと、そうではあり
ません どこのような私の本当の境界を見つけることができません
私は停止し、何か他の
ものが始まりますええと、数百、数
兆のよう
に、私の体に
は人間の細胞よりも多くの非人間の細胞さえ知らないので、私は常に
これに戻らなければなり
ません。 それらの人間以外の
ものはすべて私も
好きですが、ご存知のように、私は常に
新しいものを摂取し、古いものを排泄するようなもの
です.
私の境界はどこ
ですか?
アクティブな推論のためにこの境界が必要で
あり、マルコフブランケット
解釈を適用する必要があります.それが必ずしも真実であるかどうかはわかりません.
だから私はそれから降りることができます.
記号論的
解釈の
ような愛は、アブダクティブな意味のようですが、それは本当に重要なのでしょう
か? 共有された客観的現実のように信じていない人にとっての最も現実的な解釈
は決してうまくいかない
か、境界を見つけることができますか?
自己と他者の間のこの
境界線は何ですか、境界線を見つけることができないので
、私にとってはすべてモデル化の
観点であり、私にとってアクティブな推論ペーパーとしてのこの拉致の影響を軽減するものではありません。
私は
それが素晴らしい論文だと本当に思ったように、認知と知覚
について言うべき本当にクールなことがたくさんある
ので
、なぜ私たちはこれに電話を切ったのか、まだ
わかりません
。
いくつかのメモを
追加してください。もう 1 つ追加してください。
つまり
、このボトムアップ現象についてディーンに完全に同意する
ことだと思います。それ
はバックグラウンドで存在する
ことになります。
これらのシミュレーションは
私たちに洞察を与えてくれ
ますが、青が私に言っていることもあると思い
ます。
この全体的な境界の問題
は、システムの議論の問題がどこにあるの
かということです。
h システムはそのように定義されている
ため、何が内側に何が外側にあるか
、そして私にとっては大きな啓示で
あり、生物科学では多くの人にとって、
このように考えるのはそれほど珍しいことではない
と思いますが、エージェントベースのモデリング
を考えて、どこにあるかを考えます.
エージェンシーは目的論で
あり、
その
エージェンシーは
、システムが傾向があるのと同じように
必ずしも境界線上にある
とは限りません。
ほとんどの場合
、言説の観点からは現実にそこに
行き着くので、私たちはその言説を明確にしたいと思っていることを知っ
ています.私たちは
システムエンジニアリングでこの作業を行っており、存在論的言説
の目的のためにこれらの明確な区分が必要な場所にある
ので、私たちは
私たちが話していることとその理由を知って
いますが、おそらく
このエージェント
エージェンシーの目的論、形態学、
ダイナミクスは
それ以外のものであり、私は
それをダニエルに渡します。おそらく彼のアリはcするでしょう.
どこかで
ディーンが最初に確信が持てないので、私はそれに行きます
ここでは非常に迅速に対応するので、いくつかの
図では
ダニエルを知っていますあなたはこの
いくつかの図が得意ですマルコフブランケット
は文字通り不一致という言葉が入った楕円形な
ので
、青が言ったことに付け加えるとし
たら、もしあなたが厳しい物理的境界
が必要で、それが何であるかを発見したい
なら、あなたが探していると思う. 繰り返します
が、これはどこですか 相対論の質問
として、あることが終わり、別のことが始まるの
です。
より強力である、または
他の人に対してより大きな影響力を持っている場合、それを
関係として見ている場合、
その関係
は
不一致ゾーンとして保持されます。
必ずしも物理的な始まりと終わりがあるものではありません。
一種の流動的
であり
、これは 相対論を見るべきではないと言っているわけではありません
要するに
片方の目で相対性
ピースを見て もう片方の目で関係性ピースを見てみましょう
それの間の不一致はハードストップには向いていません
それがすべてである場合、それは不一致です
それは
、それらが異なること以外は何もわからないことを意味します
分離境界がどこにあるのかわかりませんが、
それがこの全体が
これら2つの論文をまとめようとする場所のようなもの
です。
その不一致を回避できると推測すると、
それは必ずしもパーティションである必要はありません それは
それが何であるか アフォーダンスがここにある
可能性があります
2つのことを
同時にまたは並行して保持できる
場合 教科書との
不一致 図 2 3
不一致 ブランケットやブランケット
オブ ブランケットなどの不一致
ではなく、連続値または離散値である可能性があり
ますが、
lea の非特異パスのように理想化されていません。  st action
settings
aka real settings 常に
ゼロ以外の値がある
ため、ドアを
常に少し
開いたままにしておく方法の
1 つであり、0 または 1 に 2 本の足を置いたり、0 と 1 の
迅速な切り替え戦略を
実際には実行したりしないようにします。
同じように
それを捉えて
、最初に少し尋ねた
ように、現実主義者または楽器主義者の光の中で毛布のようなものを考えるように誰かを導く理由について、そして有機体の持続性
などの要因を指摘したような青い大きな質問
その環境と流れている行動のような現実は
、環境
が現実的である場合
、一時
停止の標識が現実的であり、一時停止の標識で停止する場合、エンティティと行動と彼らの行動の記号論が現実的である場合、誰かがうまく言うように強制します。
リアルであり、それらは
すべて非平衡の定常状態の一部です
テリトリーが
あり、これがそのテリトリーの地図である
ように、それ以上のリアリズムが知りたいことは何ですか 誰かが
テリトリー
懐疑主義
にまで行き着くか、それからどのように彼らのスタンスを再構成するか、それから
ライブ ストリーム 3 でアクティブな推論における
コミュニケーションについて読んだ
とき、これは他のいくつかのランダムなピースでした。
社会的不作為の状況では、私たちは
この誘拐的な
光を社会的で活動的な環境にもたらしています。それは、社会
の
科学的および哲学的側面の多くに入る
ヒッポリュタとヴァンの論文で説明されているようなものです。
ティム・バーゲンの 4 つの質問のフレームワークから借用し、
すべて 4 つの y に似た複数の分析スケールを提供します。
これらの 4 つの y は、
2 x 2 の象限
のようなものです。したがって、
生物学の
並行研究アジェンダ
と統合
が可能になります。 ここのメカニズム側で脳の領域
が互いに接続されているという事実
は全体像の一部ですが、それは
イエスであり、
相関関係があるかどう
か、因果関係があるかどうか、それ
が因果関係か交絡因子
かその他の数のいずれかである可能性が
あり、それらのいずれにも直接
閉ざされたドアがない状況を想像できるようなDNA分岐時間 鳥のさえずりがどのように
聞こえる
かについては、鳥のさえずりがどのように解釈されるかを説明することさえせずに、
その
解釈的または記号論的な科学的
アプローチ
に
はまだスペースがあり
、研究と応用
を別の方法で検討できることを願っています。 それ
は過去の学部長の特定の分析で分割されてき
た
ので、ここで私はあなたの話を聞いているときよりもそれについて
あまり考えていないことを知って、そこに何かを投げます。
完全に間違っている場合は
誰かができる すぐに訂正してください。
これらの論文の両方が、
私が安定または安定化 ef と見なすものを提供していることは非常に興味深いと思います。
私たちが
常に考えているのは、
戦略の可能性
に対する
戦略に似たものとして説明できるものに影響を与える
ことです
. トライアドがあり、ソーシャルシーンの共同構築があると
私たちが言うとき、それは私たちが対立していないところです。
なぜなら、これらの両方が
静止安定性またはプラットフォームを提供し、
それらの予測エラーを戦略化して最小限に抑える
ことができるからです。 それでも、私たち
は戦略に基づい
て構築し、実行することができます。また、戦略に基づいて構築し、
常に悪い結果的な決定
を排除することもできます。
これら 2 つのアプローチのどちらかではなく、これら
2 つのトップダウン アプローチ
が重要なのです。 が最も影響力を持っています。
なぜなら、どちらか
一方に閉じ込められない限り、いつでもどちらか一方または両方
が実際に最も大きな影響力を持つからです。 彼らは誘導論文でさまざまなタイプの誘拐について話しているので、
オプションを生成するのではなく、オプションを選択するのが最も
多いと思いますが
、最終的には、これらのタイプの
生成と選択の
両方が本質的に
あなたができることも強調しています。 どちらか一方がなければそれはできない
ので
、ここにも組み込むのは興味深いことです。
または、検討する必要があり
ます。取り上げる必要があると
言っているわけではありませんが、そうするとどうなるでしょうか
いくつかの部分に直接応答し、
次にスティーブンは他の誰よりも
非常に興味深い
マルチスケール
予測誤差または自由エネルギー
最小化不確実性の減少
マルチスケールシステムにおける驚きの境界、
そしてヒポリタとヴァンネスが最前線にもたらしたこの社会的非アクティブな設定
それは
私たちのグリッパーであり
、固定ミラーアクティブ推論
システムまたは修道院のいずれかによって記述されたシステムで少し実験する方法で握られています
イオン力学
古典物理学 力学 統計
的熱力学 量子
ダルトンとの今後の議論の前奏曲に過ぎません
が、ベイジアン
力学
がその議論を
活性粒子の認知力学にまで広げ
ているという側面を引き出すと思います。 そのようにして、ボールの落下
は、野球が放物線の方程式に従っていないかのように説明されたとしても、具体化されたアフォーダンスに
基づいてさまざまな経路をとることができるアクティブな粒子の落下の特別なケースのようになります
が、それが実際の
環境とアクティブな粒子が相互作用する方法です
つまり、記号論的に言えば
、両方の
論文が社会的
文脈
で拉致に言及している理由であり、あなたはこれらの2つの
トップダウンの視点
と、
複数の3つの身体の
問題の間で相違がある場合、少なくとも2つの複数のアイデアがあること
を
願っています. もっと
、奇妙なアトラクタが
ありますライブstrがあります チーム 32
ライブ ストリーム 26 があります。すべてがその
空間で上から下に発生します。
なぜなら、常に下から上に複数が存在
する
ためです。そのため、確か
に正しい粗視化で
はない唯一のエラーは、モルドール レーザーの特異な
目で
あり、 それは
基本的にボトムアップの現実で予想外の予期せぬことにつながり
、トップダウンの間に発散と連続的な状態空間とパス
がある場合
、トップダウンと
ボトムアップ、またはインサイドアウトとインサイドアウトとの双方向の関係があります。
時には左から右
を時間に使用し、次に右から左
を時間に使用するシステムに違反しているように感じることなく、それらの間を移動することさえできたので、そのような
認知的動きは社交界でアクセス可能であると見なすことができ
たからです。 レーザーは発電機ではないので発電と選択
でアブダクション
の2ストロークエンジンを最後にあなたに言った
これは、
モデル化された精神的な行動を
何度か見た
ようなトークダウンシステムでの注意の
アナロジーです。スティーブンええ、ありがとう
ございます そして
、これは本当に重要だと思います。
なぜなら、アップ
が良い背景
に常に座っていたこの暗黙の悟りの仮定もあるから
です
。それは本当に興味深い
と思います。あなたは絶対に正しいと思います。
私は本当に好奇心が強いと思います、そしてそれ
はあなたのことを話します私たちはこの相互作用について話している
ので、この種の相互
作用はロビンの相互作用の究極のセットで
あり、
それが真実と見なされるもの
です。 啓蒙されたので
、そこにあるものを投影することができ
、
これから起こるのは
相互作用であるという考えは、一般的な
考え方であり、この魔法の箱
caがありました.
私たちが本当に知らなかったという事実を回避するために出現を促しました
が、それがどのように認識されているかという点ではそれは
真実ではないとは言わないでください。
真実を探求できる別の方法があります
合理的な
真実が
あり、私が究極だと思っ
たものがあります これは
非常に外見的であると
感じています これはこれらの言葉に組み込まれている
悟りの仮定ですが、
親密な真実もあります
親密な真実
は合理的な真実とは異なります
親密な真実は相互作用ではありません
それは大丈夫だと知ることです
より深い種類の知識である
ため、私が下に行くとき、それ
はボトムアップ
で何が起きているかでは
なく、私がうまくいっていることです 私が関与する唯一の方法です
それは理にかなっ
ているし、それ
はまた価値がある
ことです。それは悟りよりも原始的ではありません。
私たちが気づいていない非常に基本的な仮定は
、すべてが啓発されようとしているという科学に関するものです
が、それ
は部分的にしか真実ではなく、
生物学はそれを知っていると思います
が、とにかくそれについて話すことはできないと思います.それ
が私の小さな作品です.
その1つのレイヤーをより近くに接続しようとするために、
いくつかの学問的伝統があると思いますが、
決して
規範的なもの
ではありませんが、それらを共有してくれた皆さんに感謝し
ます。タイトルに貼り付ける伝記の1つで取られた方向性を思い出させます
これはエヴリン・フォックス・ケラーによるバーバラ・マクリントックの伝記
で、タイトルは有機体に対する感覚であり
、科学の歴史と哲学に
基づいた見方です。
例えば、有機体に対する感覚とは何か
、染色体に対する感覚はどのようにあるのでしょうか。
特定の心理学的観察
から飛び跳ねる遺伝子があったというこの信念は、誰かがプロフェッショナリズムの文脈にある
ときに実際にどのように機能するのでしょうか
そして、
外見が異なるさまざまな人々の周りの期待などの
ように、全体論的な
見方をします。これについては、すべてまたは
多くの場合
、そのような物語が語られる
と思います。
これは、進化の観点から見た青色の接続の 1 つの橋です。
そして
、スティーブンが以前に尋ねた質問の一部の
よう
に、同じ結論に到達するためにトップダウンボトムアップのように、
または同じような終点に到達するために、複数の軌道を取ることができますか？
まったく異なる
遺伝的に無関係な種が
同じ形質に到達するか、
非常によく似た外観を発達させる
ことがわかっている場合、実際には完全に無関係であった似たような外観のために、種をまとめたように、DNA関係が生じる前に人々が知っているように考えさせられます
系統発生学
のスケールで似ているか、非常に
遠い 同じ機能、または私たちは
ある種の空間の同じ議論または同じような場所に収束します。
これは私がよく考え
ていることであり、量子の
視点が
好きになるだけ
です。
別の軌道をたどる
ようにポイントをポイントしますが、すべてが時間
可逆である場合
、同じポイントに収束することはできません。
時間の可逆性が真である場合、特定のパスを
たどらなければならないため、それは実際には不可能です。 興味深いことに
、以前のフレームワークのいくつかに戻りましょう
が、
楽しいものです。ブランケット
のマークをカバーしたいことはわかっていたと思い
ますが
、
現実主義者または
さらなる
スタンスを正当化するスレッドのいくつかを調査しました 最後の 20 分間から多くの質問があります
が、
何が誰かを導くのか、
さまざまなスタンスの原因と結果がどのような意味を持つのかについて、さまざまな質問が
あり
ます。
結晶学を研究する一般的に
なぜそれが重要
なのか 意思決定やガバナンス、組織などの社会的環境にとってなぜそれが重要なのか
それは
能動的推論と互換性があり、双方向
のおそらく価値のある関係を形成するアブダクションの能力を広く正当化するものでした
推論は、
基本グラフが発明される前に説明されたこれらの認知機能を獲得します。これは、
いくつかは本当に洞察に満ちた分類があり、他のものは
偽の塊または塊などで
あり、それを別の見方をする方法が存在する前に分類されたという一種の青の提案に類似しています。
現実主義者の解釈の根拠となるものについては、現実主義者
であることの意味やそれが重要な理由についてはまだ完全に閉じられてい
ませんが、ブランケットの
不作為の概念
を打ち破り、同様にブランケットに対する彼らの角度を分解し、
おそらく何を理解しましょう 彼らを導き
、彼らが示唆する意味
そのスタンス
では、論文とすべてのスピーチアクションの両方について尋ねることができるこの認知的社会的地位をとることによって、彼らは自分
が
どのような人であると考え
ているのでしょうか。 誰もがそれのために行くことができます.
ええと
、アクションブランケットに持ち込むものは何か
、または
ヒッポリュタとヴァネッサ21ですべてがどのようにまとめられるか.
はいディーンええ、時間をかけてください.
この論文で私が本当に気に入っていることの1つは再び それ
は時間がかかることで
あり
、この共同構築の一環として
、人々が
現在の
社会的状況にいることの意味をある程度理解できるようにすること
を強く強調していることです。 それは
論文に載っていますが、彼らは
、文化的環境に慣れていない人々が、非言語的、非言語的、非表現
的なものを理解できるようになるまでにしばらく時間がかかるという事実について話しています。
の
その社会的領域内で渡され、
彼らが理解していないフォーメーションは、
何がそれを可能にするのか、そして
それは、彼らが少し時間を費やして、
なぜそれが共同構築と見なされるのかについて話し合うときです。
その状態でより多くのことを行うほど、より多くのことを
拾うことができなくなり
ます。単に見ているだけではいけませ
ん。実際、移行は
傍観者から実際の実行者へと進んでおり、それは統計的景観にかける重荷であり、重荷
です。 あなたはそこに座っ
て大丈夫で
はないので、長さを望んでいないので、私が本当に理解できないこの人が、彼らが別のことを話しているので、
彼らが何を言っているのかさえ知らない可能性はどのくらいですか.
言語
の問題は何ですか、
そこに座っ
てそのような計算
をしていないか、そうかもしれません
が、それを認識し
ていないだけで、電卓を使って計算するのに多くの時間を費やしていません.
何を
あなたが現在その一部になろうとしているこの新しいものへの積極的な関与を共同構築または調整しようとしている間の分布は何で
あるか.
これが機能するためにまず理解
しなければならない
ことは、何も変更をチェックインする前にチェックアウトした場合、その一時的なコミットメントがない場合に、何かを前進させるための一時的なコミットメントがあることです。
マークアップブランケットの観点からは何も起こらないので、それ
は本質的に
不一致の問題に戻ります。それはそれが
ハード境界であるということです。あなたはそれを理解する
こと
ができます。 これは
何ですか 進化する不一致は何ですか
どのように変化するか どのように変化するか どの
ように逸脱し、再適合
するか 最終的には何らかの合意に至るまで振動します
それはインストゥルメンタル作品
です。ほとんどの人は
そこに座ってそれを計算していません。
それが起こっているので、彼らは基本的に
、青が何を意味するのかを理解しようとしているだけです。
アクションに何かをもたらしたいと思ってい
ます その後、私たち
は非活動的な作家が何を言っているのかを見てみましょ
う。それは非
活動家と器楽主義者の
ブランケットの視点のように言われていると
思います。
著者が何を言っているのか
見てみましょう。前半で、彼らがこの質問をどのように設定したかを見てみましょう。
その後、
私たちが議論できる道の分岐点で終わります。
単語
は将来重複しますが、これはスケール
フリー ツールです スケール フリー
が別の状況
で使用されたかどうかはわかりません 解釈を可能にする統計ツールとして導入された
もので
あり、再び整数を考慮することができ
ます 慈善
的ではあるが狭い読み方をする場合
、言語はすでに
特定の
柔軟性を伝えている
ので、これが唯一の読み方ではなく
、表面下で議論が直接的
であることに加え
てどのように組み立てられるかという観点からです。 レトリックは
すぐに誘拐事件の物理的境界との関係に移り
ます.私たちは
行動の閉鎖の現実を強調し、
ループに影響を与えまし
たが、物理的境界の正当化はなかった
ので
、それは興味深いと思います. 科学的ツールとして
のマルチエージェントまたは
同様のエージェントベースのモデルの視点
が、
特定の解像度または密度から離れ
た群れのような
ぼやけたシステムをモデル化するのにどのように役立つかについての以前
の議論。
一般的なケースでそれを最初に導入するのではなく、
すでに活動的
で感覚的な状態です。  n 次に、
おそらくいくつかの状況下で
、入ってくる
意味を表し、次に出て行く意味を
表す行動の側面
のように分割されます。したがって、これらはブランケット状態の
意味と行動
です。
それからええと、eta と mu は
、お互いのフリップのような
ものです。それが、それらがこれらの文字である唯一の理由ではないと思います。これらの文字である必要はありません。
実際にそうである必要はありません。 それらの文字ですが、
これは
両方の著者が説明していることの接続構造またはスパース性
です。これが分岐
点です。アクティブな
推論は 2 つの方法で理解でき
ます。今日、私たちにはいくつかの方法があったと思い
ます。 モデルの は、ドット ドット オントロジー
のオントロジー プロパティとして存在すると予想される必要があります。
論理的な存在論的または現実
的な根拠が現実主義に関連付けられている理由です
.2番目の方法は、モデルは単なる道具であるという非現実主義者の
見解
です.
したがって、
私たち
はこれら2つの
方向の分岐点に
います.ディーン
の私の感覚 映画は
そうであり、それ
は全体を構成するものでは
なく、
トートロジー的な意味で、アクティブな推論というタイトルのトピック
を見るのではなく、積極的に推論していると言っているの
では
ありません。
複雑さ全体、
またはアクションを理解
できるように
する
ため
のものはアクティブな推論
です.
私の質問は、アクティブな
推論がこれらの各論文で実際にどのように使用さ
れているかということです.
それは
、私たちが他の心を通して理論を完全に完成させたくないという議論を築いているのでしょう
か、それとも
、私たちがあまりにも遠くに行かないようにする方法のようなアイシングのようなものの上に座っているのですか?
レール 私の主張は、
私たちが積極的に青を推測している場合、それは両方であるということです。
各論文で使用されているフランス語で
どのようにアクティブであるかはわかりません。
ドライブホームメッセージは何を意味するのか 多分
それは私たちがドットのために残しておくことができるものです.
ええと、これらすべての文字列のグラフィカルな抽象化の権利はどこにあります.ええと
、図が不足しているため、アブダクションペーパーから何かを
見つけるのは難しいです.ええと、見つけに行かなければなりませんでした.
きれいな絵のための私自身の数字では、
マルコフブランケットについて非現実主義者に
なることができることを彼らが示唆する3つの方法をさらに深く見てみましょう
。 リアリスト
プロ楽器主義者 地図
全体で政治的な羅針盤を作る
だけで、どの時代に物事がどのように定義されているかについての第2レベルの質問さえありますが、それはすべて良いことです。
2 つの極の間にある 2 つのシダの間のこの連続した空間をナビゲートするような状態に戻した方法は
、少なくとも
、一種の動的な
ナビゲーション設定
にとどまり、もしあなたが蛾なら、それができれば
「ランタンに近づきすぎ
ないでください。ランタンにぶつかると死ぬ
ので、フライトはそこで止まります。
そのため
、非常に
意味のある解釈レイヤーを配置すると思い
ます。
前述のように、数字は
解釈
に役立ち、短いリストは3つの理由があるように役立ちます。
なぜ私はここでこれに反対するのか
それらは 1 2 と 3 です これらは
重要な構造
ですが、人々が特定の状況以外で
アウトラインを介してコミュニケーションをとらない理由もあり
ます
マルコフブランケットについて非現実主義者であること
意味のない
ツールの意味
これは非常に興味深いと思います
それらは意味的価値を保持していません 解釈的価値
言語 科学者が一時停止の標識を研究している状況での行動を理解または予測するためにそれらを
使用することによって構築されたものとは異なり
、科学者は
言うことができますが、私の場合の統計的優位性
は
手段として使用されて
おり、有効なスタンス
がありますが、特に
セマンティックに非常によく似たこの記号論的な見方をする
と、それらは似たような種を持っていますが、
一時停止の標識と実際の停止を伴う記号論と、停止
の社会的および行動
と、
彼らがその信念を持つことにつながったエージェントの開発
単に命題論理の
観点から
それを設定するだけで
はないコンテキスト.
発生する選択サイクルには
、内部外部およびその間のすべてから
生じる構造化された新規性が少なくとも含まれ
ます。
注意などに関する分布と戦略
なので、潜在的にセマンティックよりもはるかに豊富な設定
です。
これは、特定の
設定でシンボリックを意味する可能性があります。つまり、チューリング マシンのように
実行されるシンボリック ロジックの種類であり、
まだ広範囲に及ぶ可能性がある
ため、寛大な
解釈はまだ非常に
もっともらしいです
が、別の論文で言及された記号論と生セミオティックについて何か異なるものがあります。
それは、研究者がモデリングしたものとはまったく同じではなく
、2016年の
論文でイエロー・バーンバーグによって十分に調査されました。 彼
は、科学的分析
法
と認識システムを認識器として対比し、生態心理学を通じて
認知科学をある意味で区別する科学者ではありません。
学部長
はい、私は
それにタグを
付けるつもりでした。 理論的には
、私たち
は以前の結果を待っていないと言うのは簡単です。
しかし、本当に厳格な科学的スタンス
を取っているときでさえ、私たちのほとんどは、無意識のうちに適用し
た優先順位と重みを認識している
とは
思いません。
いいえ、これに付加価値はありません。
私は自分自身を
そこから取り除いただけであり、私はそれを受動的に観察しているだけですが、
重みを適用し始める前にどのくらい受動的であるかはわかりません。
特に個人的な
状況分析で分析して
いることを重視し、結果
は私たちに降りかかります。今、あなたが単に
何かを見ているだけで、観察者としてのあなたには何の影響もありません
その方が簡単かもしれません
が、科学者が実験に参加している場所に
たどり着い
たら、
そのスイッチがどのようにオフになり、
非常に
強力で真実で、多くの点で
暗黙のうちに、  e 私が情報環境でときどき目に
するような明確なメッセージは、人々に以前のこと
を更新させて
、絶対に有効な
コミュニケーションと視点
であるより大きな問題に含まれていると信じさせること
であり、経路
と恒常性と マルチレベル
システム
とそれがたどらなければならないクリティカルパスには
、再帰性と物語と
期待が含まれます。
このボトムアップ、トップダウンの
側面
は
、人々がさまざまな設定にさまざまな社会構造があり、実際にはそうではないと主張できるように
、社会
的怠慢です。 トップボトム
である必要はありません。特定の比喩やレンズのような心理精神分析である必要はありません。
基本的には、
ええと、その複雑さをすべてデータポイントに折りたたむための1つの近道です。
この1つのトリック
は
、実験のようにアプローチすることです。
ある意味では、それが実験であり、
このチューブがこの DNA 鎖とこれを持っているようなマニホールドを見つけることです。
これにより
、壁のペンキや真のコンテキストの他のすべての
要素を、
部分的な情報のカプセル化
やその他のタイプのシステムから分離できる
ようになり、量子のように見える可能性が
あります。
物事が常に見かけどおりではないことを示唆する持続的
な異常
は、実際のケーススタディは
量子力学ではなく、すべての社会的および行動的設定におけるあらゆる種類の人々による
心理学研究
、神経画像研究、および
行動研究を伴うベイジアン力学です。
そして
[音楽]
は、社会的および認知システムの相互作用主義の正式なモデル化のより深い意味のいくつ
かを実際に指し示しています。人
はその現実の生活から抜け出し、
別の生活に入り
、第三者の視点のように自分自身を位置づけ、
これを振り返ることができます。 シングル パス プレーン
を試してみてください。
しかし、その観察者
は実在主義と道具主義を主張することができます
その見解に関して人々はどこから話して
いるのかわかりません 私はちょうどそのようなことを育てているだけ
です あなたは
どこに
いるのですか そしてそれは自己概念に本当に関連しています
青は育ち
、自己
概念と現実主義者の器楽主義者のような状況のようなものを好みます
が、これらの点に移りましょう
マークアップブランケットについて非現実主義者になることが
できる2番目の理由 単にそれらを貴重なフィクションと見なすことができ
ます はい 抽象化を可能にする
現象の特定の特徴ですが、
人が尋ねることができる価値のあるフィクションは、生成された解釈のすべてです
フィクションの価値があるかどうか、
またはそうです
それがフィクションであると言って、すべてがフィクションであると言うの
は、ええと
、それがどのように道具的であるか、または
どのようにそれが何であるかということです 現実主義者
は、原子について誰かが教えられた可能性
があるものではないが、それがすべてのものであるという本当の主張をしている
特定の教室で
は、永続的な相違
により、そのうちの1つは
科学的に根拠があり、もう1つは
形而上学的に根拠が
あり、または好みの信仰
やその他の
好みや懸念がその
議論に入る可能性がある
と考える人が
いる可能性があります。 マルコフブランケットについて非現実主義者で
あること
つまり、円軌道モデルが 99 に
うまく適合している
という理由だけで、
誰かが
まったく異なるモデル構造で 99.9 になるまでは、実際には周転円
であるという
ことです。
科学的プロセスへのコミットメントの一環として、彼らがドアを離れる可能性がある場合のモデル
より高い説明予測力の設計と制御などを備えたいくつかの将来のモデルに開かれています。
ディーン
はい、それがどこにあるのかわかりません。
今朝の47-0からのスライドを見ていました。
他の論文でハイライトされている部分があります
.ピアスがドアを開けたままにしておくと言っている部分があり
ます.それは拉致について
です.単にドアは瓶です.
仮説は最善の説明では
なく、
何かではないというよりもむしろ最善の説明
ですが、今では何か
を動かし
て活用する
ことができます。それは、ドアが開いたままになっているためです。
この結論では、
3番目のものは
器楽主義者のレンズを通してマルコフブランケットの成功です
が、現実主義者の側に
も同じことを言って
いる人がいますが、よりオープンであるほど、あなたがそうである可能性が高くなります.
実際にはすぐに詳細に到達します。これ
は
楽しい
アリの例で、スティーブンの以前の要求に戻すようなものです。
ええと、速いほうが遅い、または遅い
ほうが速いという
ものがあります。両方の方法を想像することはできますが、
アリでの経験的な発見は、
警報フェロモンがまき散らさ
れた部屋を出るなどの特定の脱出避難状況 出口に狭窄のようなものがある場合
車の交通渋滞や人混みの状況での状況での狭窄がある場合に彼らが構築した巣の形態
は、 非常に
致命的であり
、押しつぶされた
状況や液体から固体
が詰まったようなもの、そして骨折が
発生した場所の中心にあらゆる種類の問題を引き起こす可能性があります
が、アリでは
個々の動きが遅くなります
誰もが列に並ぶ整然とした列ではなかったので、今は
番号を待つので、そう
呼ばれるの
が
彼らの反応のようなものでした
バイオセミオティックス
とニッチ構造のエスケープ
ライトの状況で
は、応答が遅くなるほど応答が速くなり
、巣の仲間としての形態は、物理的に絶縁
されている足を白くすることで好きになるのに役立ち
ます。
これ
は
、人間が
物理的な逃避環境で意味的に心に留めておくべき唯一のことです
が、アクティブな推論
により、
それらの異なる設定
に戻り、アリ
とそのビューを内部から見ることができます。
フェロモンの知覚のような内部
共生 ネスト
メイト、そして科学者との外部共生
があり、ディーンの
楽器が演奏されている
ので、ティムの代わりにタムになるアリの心を通して考えていません
が、ハイブマインドが働いているという感覚があります
あなたは必ずしもその隠れた心を共有することはできません
が、ブレンドはありません。
自律
性があり、もし私がトップDを信じているなら、という感覚があり
ます。
アクティビズムによって可能になる独自のバージョン
私がそれを信じているなら 現実主義者
の心を通して考えることなく理解できる
その現実主義者の視点が何であるか
ですから、
あなたはそうではありません
論理的な観点からトーマスとイネスが書いたことは非常に理にかなっ
ていると言いますが、それは
私の私の考え
とこの別の考え方
が共存することから
私を失格させるものではありません
。 答えがダニエルを見ているか
どうかである場合、アリが彼に気づいたときについてダニエルが私たちと共有する別の物語があるかもしれませんが
、簡単な話をしましょう。
私はカササギに餌
をやります。
彼らは顔を認識するのが非常に速いので、それは私だと気づきました。彼らが
することは、彼ら
が好意を
返すことです。
私
が犬のfを置く岩 彼らはこれを愛しているので、この魚風味のドッグフードを愛しているので、
彼らは
実際に物を返し、貢献し
ています.
私の心は
確かに戦略の観点から私の行動に影響を与えたいと思っていることを
知っています.そこには多くの点があり
ます. 意図的
なスタンス
は、複雑なホロビオント ブルース
マイクロ
バイオームと人間の犬のサプライ チェーンの
カラスの
設定を
可能にする汎戦略主義であり、ゲームのプラグマティズムのために、
意思決定制御理論ゲーム理論などによってそれらが存在し、モデル化されることを可能にします。
これらすべての状況
を、いくつかのゲームをプレイして、いくつかの
ゲームを通じて
この方法で勝つか、または それは
非常に興味深い
アイデアであり
、ゲームやアートなどを通じて
さまざまな種類のコミュニケーションを可能に
する経験をデザインし、アブダクティブペーパーの要点
について考えるのはクールだろう. ピアソンの概念の議論に戻ることができる科学の経済 それは
レビュアーの心を通して考えるようなものであり
、私の胸の相手の心を通して側面を見たり考えたりするだけです
それは完全なエミュレーション
[音楽]
ではなく、
インターフェースアフォーダンスを生成することができます ポリシー
では、エンティティが生成しなければならない部分的な情報状況が非常に多く
、生成範囲
は、強力な選択メカニズムも必要であることを意味します。
これらは
、帰納的演繹的
静的概念
弁証法から私たちを打ち破る一時的な抽象論理のサイクルです。
これはプラグマティズム、行動、
生態学的心理学などをもたらします。
何
千年も前からある、知覚
認知と行動の正式なモデルの空間内で何が流れているかを見るのは本当に魅力的です。これらのさまざまなスレッドの多くを理解することが重要です。
社会的および活動的な論文は
、最も重要な分野の2つを示してい
ます.ディーンは
そうです.それについてはすぐに説明
します.
非常に現実的な
贈与
贈与の演習が行われている、または
少なくとも私はそれを贈与の演習として解釈しています。これは、
私が取ることができる1つのアプローチであり、私が取ることができる他のアプローチ
は、トークン交換に関して非常に道具主義
的なものになるでしょう。 物事
はうまくいくだろう それらを一緒に
する
と
、さらに付加的なもの
になるかもしれない 混乱を招くとは思わない
ヒッポリュタとヴァネッサの図 2 と
3 を見
ているのと同じプロセスで私は、
非活動主義者または非活動的推論の
観点から引き出された社会構築の観点を示します。
図 3 との違いは、
図 2 の社会的行動です。
アクティブな推論フレームワークの下で
はカップリング
であるため
、図 3 の中央にある
この灰色のボックスで捉えられるようなものは 1 つもないように思われます。
それは
非常に重要なノードと解釈の 1 つであり
、チューブを介して、それを見て「はい」と言うアブダクティブ レビュアーにあなたが知っていることを渡します。
社会的アクターはアブダクティブ ロジックに関与し
ています。ピアスでの私の背景
は、世代選択
と 時間のダイナミクスと、ピアースの作品のアブダクションからの環境との行動の流れは
、現実主義の枠組みで解釈できる
ため、この ca  n この目でこのビューで手段として保持されると
、
次に、
誘拐論理を使用してモデル化している誘拐が
手段としてのスタンスを保持できるかどうかを尋ねることができますが、
それは
内部記号論の代わりに社会的アクターにとって手段となりますか?
アクソセミオーシスブルーから、
あなたは私の口から言葉をすぐに取り出し
ました。良い仕事です。
この灰色のボックスは、この
社会文化的意味とモデルベースの
推論の
ようなものです。 フィルターの
ようなものは
、社会文化的意味の代入のようなエキソセミオーシスで
あり、モデルベースの推論は、
私が
見た使用法で見た定義から
のエキソサミ
オーシス
です。 構築プロセスを意味する
ので
、外部共生は外部からのビュー
です。たとえば、一時停止の標識の
状況を見て展開します。アリのフェロモンの状況を見て展開します
。unf 古いの
に対し、エンドセミオーシスは
解釈的な記号論的プロセスであり
、それによって何かが内部的な意味を持つようになり、
それ
が象徴的なものなのか、認知的なものなのか、注意の方法なのか、
これらすべての異なる
側面にあるのかを尋ねることができますが
、とにかくそれが正確な区別であることを願ってい
ます. あなたは実際にあなたです
私はこれ
を私の小さな脳のために簡単にしようとしています.あなた
は人が第三者の視点を取ることができるかどうか
を尋ねて
います. このエキソ セミオーシスのように
、私が好きなときのように、私が好きなときにそれを見てください 右
のように 内部セミオーシスは内部へのシグナル伝達の
ようなものです それは内部共生のようなものです
ええと
、内部へのサインの解釈のようなものですが、このように
外部共生は生物間のようなものです
同じ種または異なる種の生物間の記号の解釈
とシグナル伝達の
ように、たとえば
、  nt フェロモンのようなものは、私がエキソサスとして読んだもの
です。その図を見ると、
エキソシスではなく
、モデル表現のように見えます。
そこにある他のものは何だったので、探して
います エキソについては
そうです、ここで私たちは同意していると思います
エンドソームは生物内のシグナル伝達
または内部からの眺めのような
ものですが、そこには
物理的な境界と機能的な境界の中心もある
ので、全体があります
生物
記号論の複雑さは、通常、人々が生物記号論について話し、その分割について
早すぎる立場をとるのではなく、複雑さを認識する理由だと思います
が、
これは地球外生命体と
される人へのメッセージを構築するエクソソマティック
な視点です。 ここにリストされている
その論文の著者である著者は
、コーチのダグラスです
が、そうですね、
まあ、これは社会文化的な意味の代入のようなものです。
ええと、ダニエルと私が出したばかりのミーム紙のよう
に、
ええと、rjとマリファの場合、
この記号論的表現は
文化
的に相対的な
ものです。 アボリジニは
ネイティブの原始的なライフスタイルのように非常に似ている
ので、
このエキソの外部共生
は、同じ種の生物間の伝達の
ようなものですが、同じ文化のようなものでも
あります。
それがフェロモンに当てはまるかどうかはわかりません.
フェロモンと
異なるアリの種が
異なることを意味するかどうか.同じ
フェロモンが複数の意味を持つことができる
かのように.それも真実であるか、同じような種類の分子
化合物
です.
私はあなたが
今求めていること
を
理解
して
いると
思います
遠い過去にはおそらく存在し
なかった何かが存在していたという嘘は、別の文脈では存在しなかったでしょう。
言うまでもなく、同じ言語を話しているが語彙が異なる人々のように、さまざまな軸に沿ってさまざまな親密さがあり
ます。または
、状況が非常に重要であることを知っている場合は、ボディーランゲージが重要であり
、認知
構造が
それがどうなるかと比べて離れているか、異なります。 引用するのが難しい 彼らの立場に身を置く
など ええと、それ
はマルチスケールのシステム現象に関する大きな問題だと思い
ます それらが散逸的であるか持続的であるか
多様な知性
私たちが泳ぐ水
が認知的および言語的に何であるかを理解
する 水は 私たちはいくつかの中で泳ぎ
ます それは他の何かのためのシグナルになるでしょう
それはアクティのbマトリックスのような影響シグナルになる可能性があり
ます
あなたが泳ぐ水の一部として、世界の因果関係に
影響を与えることは、あなたが泳ぐ水のような物理的な影響のようなニッチな変更による変更の
ようなものかもしれません.
あなたが来て、私たちを通して私
たちが意識を向けていない
ので、それらは
DNA
を増幅するPCR実験の壁の
ペンキのようなもの
です. パス
、そしてそれは私たちのように局所的な部分情報から私たちのような意味を作ります。
まるで目に見えない部分の多くを
無視することができ
、クリスフィールドと
量子のように情報を燃やさなければならないような排気熱のように話しているように認知的に行います。
注意
を払い、したがって、本当に複雑なニッチに対処するために注意を払う必要があります。そのため
、その道には多くの緊張があり、
特にこのダイアドに関しては、
そう確信しています。 他の多くの関連作業ですが、
このダイアド
と私は、
ディーンがそれにアプローチするのを手伝ったレンズで、
ええと
、それらの
スレッドのいくつかを別の光に当てている
と思います。
コンセプトの証明のような社会的不作為のようなものです
が、
腐食したものやパフォーマンスアートでは
ありませんが、パフォーマンスアートではないと誰が言うことができますか?
ディーン、そしてブルー
私はこれらの紙の両方を柱と見なすと思います.
さまざまな理由で本当に安定していると思います.
両方の足で立ち、
両方の下に安定したものを置いて、
上に立とうとします. 片方または
両方の足を 1 つのシリンダーの上に置いて立っているの
は、自分のフォームだけでは難しいと思う
からですが、ライブ ストリームの新しいシーズンを取り上げようとし
たとき
フロンティアの瞬間のように感じられた 2 つの論文をまとめる
と、私たちが伝えたかったことの 1 つは、
一度に 2 つのものを見ることは
本質的に複雑であると
は限らないということです。複雑さ
はそれぞれの論文に存在しますが、
一度に2つのものを見ること
はより複雑であり、それゆえに
試行錯誤の
関係の誤りをはらんでいます 私たちがたくさんの間違いを犯したと言っているわけではありません
が
、最初の生成の最初のルールは
あなたはすぐにそれ
を手に入れることはでき
ません.あなたが行くと思っているところに行くことができるようにするために、その一時的なコミットメントを再び持つ必要があります.
私はこれがどこに行くのか本当に知りませんでした
注目の体制を狭めないとどうなるのだろう
か 必ずしもそれを広げていることを知っていたわけではありません
が、ある時点
で著者が来て、
なぜこれら2つを選ぶのかと尋ねるかもしれないことは知っていました. 考える
必然的にこれらの2つの紙である
ということ
は、これらの紙の両方が
素晴らしい交響曲を作成し、作成するということです。
したがって
、ショコラティエ
またはワイン愛好家が本当に
ペアリングを特別なものにするのに必要な紙のセットである可能性がありますが、ペアリングが行われる
他の
状況があります
時々私が思う
ように、あなたは
常にゼロから1つのコンテキストの間で共有し
、その連続体のどこにいても、
あなたが共有している素晴らしい部分とあなたが共有
している部分を共有します。  「
違いはあります
が、2つの論文の重複も尊重できます。
言葉の使い方が反対
でしたか、別の方法で反対のようでした。
それからスタンス
で、ええと
、
人々が持っているゲームのようなものを考えました。
熱帯の美しい場所で 1 本のポールに立ち
、転ばないようにします
dは、あなたの
非平衡定常状態への攻撃です。
特に、例として、
これらの1人のうちの1人が
教授
になるような場合は、
ええと、
抵抗
して固定モードに戻っ
てみませんか?
ダルトンとマクスウェルの最近の研究
のいくつかで、固定モードが重心である
と聞いたことがあります。それから、あなたが説明する別の方法は、
ゼロ以外の
発散を持ち、その間のスペースが
バスケットボールのトリプルスレットスタンスに似ている
ためです。 バスケットに行くようにドリブルしたり、パスしたり、シュートしたりできます。
ええと、それは別のスタンス
であり、アフォーダンスの分野でもある
ため
、ここの足
が幅よりもはるかに広くないなど、異なる位置にいるだけではありません。 ここに足があります
が、これは
ピアスが
ほのめかしたよう
に、調査のムードです。
行動と生態学的心理学
との文脈
で、楽器
とゲーム
とサムとの文脈ですべてのことをほのめかしたでしょう ゲームを
サポートしていたゲームの外の
もの これらのレベル
はすべて三重の脅威にありますが、どう
やってここに来たのです
か なぜ私はグリーンにいるのですか
限られたコンテキストで
あり、
はい、まだ非常に熟練してい
ます
どれだけのエネルギーが注がれているのか誰も疑問に思っていません
それは大変な作業
であり、それをうまく行うことには大きな報酬
があり、たくさんあるので、私は
完全に同意
し、人々がこれのために多くのトレーニングをした可能性があることにまったく同意し、そのつもりはありません
でした。
バスケットボール
をするので、少し動的で状況に応じたものにする必要があり
ますが、拡張された紙の解釈のメタファーで紙の解釈の極端なモードのような
ものとして見るだけで、文学や談話から記号論を受け取るさまざまなモードを見ることができます。
それは参加
とフィードバックの役割であり、それから
私たちが言及したそのマルチエージェントの設定は
、私たちの最後のところであまりにもランダムではないことを願っています
私
がしたいと思っていた論文のペアリングのように、この
アブダクティブ推論論文と
クリスフィールドの量子論文
は40からの
ものです。
アブダクティブ
推論
とそれがどのように見えるかについて学ぶのと同じように、
アブダクティブ推論では
完全な情報を持っていないことを知っているように、部分的に
観察可能であり
、部分的な観察から最善の予測
を行い、 私は、あなたがそれを好まないオーバーラップする量子参照フレームのように考えています.
他の誰かの量子参照フレームと完全にオーバーラップすることはできません.
完璧な学習を
行っても、まだいくつかのノイズ
またはオーバーラップが発生する. 量子
参照の間、または
um量子参照フレーム間の何らかの不一致
重複していない領域があるため、わかりません
これは、私が見たいと思っていた1つのペアリングのようなものです。それ
は、以前にほのめかされたように、科学の哲学における
反射性の問題
[音楽]
で量子がガラスを割った
ように、本当に興味深いものです。 建物の唯一の
部分またはガラスの弱体
化であるが、
実験的文脈に関する前述の永続的な異常は
、過去500年ほどの間、特定の文化界での言説を超えて科学における特定の問題の範囲を拡大し、
スティーブンは量子の一部をほのめかした.
ここで、この
誘拐的な時間的関係性は
そこにあります 今見ると、それは
プロトアクティブな粒子ではありません ああ、もし電子
がただの小石だったら、
これは起こらないでしょう
、または電子がもっと大きな小石だったら、
これは起こらないでしょうが、起こら
ないでしょう 点と粒子と wa に関するこれらすべての質問をより適切に測定できるため、起こっているか、または起こっていないでしょうか。
認識粒子の力学としてのベイジアン力学の下で ves
反射性は電子スケールからだけでなく流れ込むことができる
ようになり
ましたが、記号論
的な物語の
生態系
では、実験外の実際のスケールで反射性を備えた複数の接触サービス
があるように感じます。 私たちがこれ
に入った方法について部分的に語っています.1つの
議論も
そうです.最後の
5分から10分で
何をしたいです
か.4.2著者だけに注意してください
.
ドット 2 の場合でも
、将来の任意の時点でも、ドット
3 のアフォーダンスが常に存在するため、
作成
した人やまだ作成していない人とこの議論を続けたいと考えています。
このベクトルに基づいて構築し
ますので、ディーン um がもたらした来週の議論で
話したい点があれば、自由に言及してください。
前に
どこにアクティブな推論があるのか
れはそれが基礎である
のか、そこにある種の二元性がある
のか 、それは私が各論文を
振り返ってみたいと思うものだと思います
。 アクティブな推論をその柱またはその柱に配置したい場所はどこですか、
それとも柱ですか?わかりませんええ
、アクティブな推論の色付き蛍光
ペンを使用して、これらの2つの単語はいまたはあなたと言うことができますか?
この条項を知っている はい、この段落
とこの論文またはこの論文の
相互作用 この論文
によって開発されたこのツール 私が紙
のディーンを見た方法を強調するために探しているの
は、
ステファンが
ルークに完全に同意することを知っているからです。
彼の推論行為の括弧内の後ろにある
理由は、
もし私たちがアブダクティヴ・ロジックとレトロダクションについて話しているなら、それは非常に重要だと思うからです。
私たちが他の書類を引っ張って
絡ませたらどう
なるでしょうか。それがきっかけである
といいのですが、
2つの書類をまとめるには信じられ
ないほどの準備が必要であり、その仕事の量を適切に尊重しません。
その仕事の創始者
はそう
しました.1つの論文がそれを正当化するためにそれを定量化するという点で準備が何であれ、
2つの論文を引用することはそれの何倍にもなります.
対象分野の専門家は
、その演習は文字通り困難であり、
時間もかかるものである
と積極的に推測して
います。今日、ここでゲームについてかなり話し合ったので、文字通りゲームを変える
と考えています。
ゲーム
は
全員がカヌーに乗り込み、
協力して
ハワイの島々にたどり着くことが
でき、文字通り文字通りゲームになる可能性があります。 競争
である必要はありません レースではありません ここで収集する必要
がある限られた量の情報
を考えると、
私たちは生き残ることができます 続行する能力にとって重要である
と考えています
それが
、主題の
専門家から予測の
専門家への移行が実際に移行する場所な
ので
、本当に危険な方法でぶらぶらし
ているように感じる人たちにもう一度感謝したいです。
認識論的空間にいて
、
ホメオスタシス変数を
確保して、驚くべき空間を開き
、誘拐の時間的側面に近づくことが名誉であり特権であることを
願っ
ています. これら
の接触点 コミュニケーション
は動的
である 類似の方程式と数学記号に関して、どちらの論文でも唯一の形式主義であったもの
それはダイナの 3 つの表現であった
ヒポリトとヴァンネスのミカルシステム
彼らが
スタンスをとっていた場所から接触点を接続して接地
し
、数学的象徴
科学への熟練したパフォーマンス 誰かがこの論文は
哲学論文だと言います はい、それは
方程式を持っ
ているので、そうなるでしょう 何か
違う
ええと、
あなたは論文を読むとゲームが変わると思って
いましたが、複数の論文を読むと
ゲームが
変わります. 私は
、人々
が
自分の考えから広範に発言せず、
エンドソームの観点から、
または私には信じがたいように思われる文化全体のように、自明ではないものとの関係
で自分自身のエキソサスを位置付けるときに、自分自身を家にいるように感じます。
内部共生
と、これらの 2 つの
糸がブランケットのどこ
で出会うかは
、潜在的に最もエレガントな
粗視化で
表されます ここの灰色のボックスで
、なぜ境界を定めたり、グリップしたりする必要があるのでしょうか?
おそらく、この時点で私たちが持っているグリッパー
は
車のペンチのような
ものであり、これは非常に異なるもので
あり、またはアクティブなものである
ため
、この時点または任意の時点で完全に有効であるように思われ
ます
図 2 と図 3 の構造を見て、
非常に多くのスタンス
を一度に保持したり、迅速な
ナビゲーションを行ったりする
ことはとても楽しい議論
でした。青とディーンに参加してくれたスティーブンに感謝
します。
ドット 2 以降でいくつかの興味深い時間を楽しみにしています。
安らかに